what's normal to do in Japan for like
New Year's what's like the tradition
here the tradition is to do you have to
go to like a temple right yeah Temple oh
that's usually a news day okay
um but like for me like this year I'm
going back to my Grandma's place up
north uh because like it's very much
like it's weird like Christmas and you
mean you already went to your Grandma's
place yeah it's the New Years the New
Year fantastic I loved it
um yeah so I think it's it's interesting
because like I thought about this it's
like Christmas and New Year's how it's
celebrated in the west is like the
complete opposite to how to celebrate in
Japan yeah because it's like in the west
it's like Christmas is for the family
and then New Year's is where you get
sloshed with your mates right right but
in Japan it's the opposite Christmas is
like a couple's thing or you get sloshed
with your single friends
I've been there yeah and New Year's is
when you go back home and you spend it
with your family right right and so like
at least for me like the tradition is
like usually I go back to my Grandma's
place like a few days before New Year's
Eve and then we do like a big like final
cleanup of the house to kind of like you
know not to like physically clean up the
house but also just like to refresh
ourselves like you know for the upcoming
year that's what they say yeah you come
in and clean my house right yeah it's
just an excuse for my grandma to be my
clean my house [ __ ]
um so I go there I clean the house and
then
um we have this thing called
which is uh which is you have this bowl
of soba uh as your final meal
um and uh for the year not yeah
yeah it's uh and uh I don't remember
what the exact reasoning behind why you
eat the sobos but there's like some kind
of uh like traditional reasoning behind
why you would do it
um so then you would eat that and then
the New Years happens then you go to the
temple first thing in the morning
usually uh to do like you know your
first prayers and stuff like that and
then you eat osichi which is like a type
of uh traditional Japanese like huge
[ __ ] platter of like I think like 50
different things like small little
different things like imagine what you
get I think I've seen this you can I've
seen this to be able to book it yeah
I've seen it yeah you usually usually
you book it I mean people who are like
pros just like make it themselves
um but like uh think of like you know
like the breakfast at a dualcon think of
that by like four times yeah yeah and
you share it among your entire
and it's really good but it's like it's
definitely something you can't have is
it is it like the chocolate boxes where
there's like Everyone likes a certain
the one chocolate and everyone's like
yeah I have yo can I have that yeah can
I have like that then I'm good I don't
want the [ __ ] squid [ __ ] I'm good yeah
there's always like there's always like
two or three that are just like
untouched
looks nice it's just there for variation
help yourself
um I feel like there are some real items
that people just buy just for like oh
it's just because everyone else bought
it before yeah do you have um like
quality Street in Australia also okay
[ __ ] that's a British thing qualis like
the chocolate quality street so you have
a quality high quality Street yeah I've
heard it it's like uh kind of like uh
just a different type of chocolates
right it's a lot of is it a different
colored ones yes yeah it's like there's
like a triangle that's perfect yeah I've
seen it before I think yeah and and I
think there was a certain episode of Qi
that was like they everyone the favorite
pieces that Everyone likes they
purposely put Less in the box of which
is [ __ ] is cruel it's cruel is that
true yeah [ __ ]
yeah these swindled Bamboozled lights I
was like that's [ __ ] up bro that's
just a waste of food man you could you
could have more chocolate if people are
easy over there they don't want to put
the good stuff in the good stuff's
expensive
it's annoying they probably do that with
uh yeah they probably do that with like
a bunch of different ones right I'm sure
do you have celebrations yeah okay you
have those we have those yeah I've tried
any Americans best ones not British
people are like what the [ __ ]
celebrations there's only like two of
the best ones what is it what is the
best best two in the celebrations I feel
like most of the celebrations I like
most of them but the the malteser one is
the best Maltese it's like a chocolate
malteser one what what chocolates are in
there this is so British now yeah we're
going to British chocolates okay but it
might be different because like do you
guys have cherry ripe the [ __ ] is that
okay that's Australian what the [ __ ] is
that that's the best one yeah see Kai
knows what's up what is it explain that
to me cherry ripe is uh it's this it's
this chocolate bar that has like kind of
I don't know I don't even know what the
hell it is it's this cherry flavored
something inside of it it's like Cherry
chocolate
um I I actually don't know what it is I
don't care what it is it's delicious
yeah okay so in British celebrations uh
it's kind of like a box of different
kind of famous chocolate bars just like
in very very tiny candy form so we have
maltesers Mars Bars Wicks Snickers yeah
Milky Way Bounty Galaxy and uh Galaxy
caramel and I think galaxy is the best
yes dude maltesers teasers are the goat
dude if you haven't you've got to have
one of these
um if you come to the UK at some point
I'm sure we because we need it outside
but it's a very very festive thing as
well people buy them okay
yeah they advertise hard for the
holidays dude okay I don't know if it's
a white people thing but they're in like
every white person's home
I'm like I have to reframe how I view
the UK I'm like another it's not the UK
it's so it's the white people
because I only have experience in the UK
through the lens of white people because
I'm obviously White
yeah yeah I mean it's it's kind of like
me with Easter chocolates where I I [ __ ]
that this is overrated he says I like
the Easter chocolates I don't know why
and you could you could have like a like
a cadre's Milk Bar uh milk chocolate bar
and I'm like I will buy the egg version
eating it in egg form I don't know just
tastes makes it taste so much better I
don't know why did something about like
slowly breaking off it is it is right it
is I don't know why this is a thing but
this is so [ __ ] British and I'm
saying out loud often when you buy these
uh these Easter eggs in the UK they come
in these boxes for some reason they
always come with mugs
they would like you would get an Easter
egg that would come with a mug that was
branded like it was Cadbury's it would
be a mug a very cheap mug with the
Cadbury's logo on it right and this was
a thing like did you have this in
Australia so this was like it was you'd
always get the chocolate bar and a mug
do you remember this I remember this
yeah and then I realized like oh wait I
remembered in University everyone would
bring mugs and stuff and I swear half
the [ __ ] mugs were just Easter egg
mugs because they're the cheapest
shittest mugs that your parents wouldn't
mind letting you take to you right right
do you remember seeing these now all the
time in University now that you're
mining now they remind me I'm just
having a lot [ __ ] yeah you're the wave I
remember I see the [ __ ] Cadbury and
KitKat logo on these [ __ ] mugs all
the time dude it looks so [ __ ] let me
pull it up I'm gonna pull this up it
looks so pathetic
imagine Easter eggs mugs it's those ones
it's those ones
it would come like this it would come
like this right it's like it would it
would be the egg in the mug or like
adjacent to it and this was like I've
never seen that yeah it was everywhere
like every single [ __ ] chocolate bar
did this it was insane and now I think
about it I'm like why the [ __ ] do we
want so many mugs this is too many mugs
to the team yeah but I already have mugs
but that's that's the thing about every
like British home there is oh there
always there is always an overabundance
of mugs oh sorry it's and there's the
nice mugs and these are the shittiest
the shits and if you ever go to like a
government building or you ever go to a
hospital and or any kind of thing and
you get a cup of tea guaranteeing it's
coming out in a mug the exact same
quality as this one thank God because
they're like they're like the
replaceable marks yeah because like the
actual good mugs no one gets those no
one's allowed so once you're finished
with that we just Chuck it under water
probably before you throw it away did
you ever have like did your household
ever had like a soft tier list of like
mugs in your home you know so you know
you have like the cheap ones but when
you like want to treat yourself yeah you
have like your purse there was there was
like two or three mugs whereas my dad
was just like those are my [ __ ]
months don't touch it because it was
like some mugs were like China like with
some nice quality yeah they're still
Murray's and whenever I used it my mum
wanted a cup of tea she's like why do
you keep using the mug I like that's my
mind I'm like I thought you weren't
gonna have a tea so I took it I I just
thought it was okay because you're such
a good mom like I swear to God every
British person has like everything
everyone has a favorite has that one MOG
West they become like Sheldon Big Bang
oh yeah it's just like don't use this
mug this is my mug we have every British
person is like this because everyone
drinks so much [ __ ] coffee you need a
mug you need the goat mug and I yeah I
like ones that are like I've come to
become very fond of like deep very like
cylindrical mugs not the ones that like
curve up just just a [ __ ] cylinder
chop it off boom big mug I hate the ones
that like curve up like those ones
they're [ __ ] like teacup looking ones
yeah I'm not a big fan of those I just
want this like literally a perfect
cylinder just chop chop it in half boom
that's the model give it to me I like
the uh kind of like oval shaped ones
yeah they're pretty like that oh like
like yeah like this one like the kind of
dumpy yeah like literally like this one
maybe like a little bigger yeah kind of
kind of feels like I'm drinking from the
Medieval ages or something I don't know
something about talking about it's not
medieval
I mean so some of the designs I have in
my house also my mum has so much [ __ ]
yeah your dude your mom has a collection
your mum mum's house feels like a Looney
Tunes accident waiting now it is you go
you walk in and you're like I can't
touch anything if I touch a wall
everything will break it's like a fully
artist nightmare between VR in the
living room
with this [ __ ] China all over the
world
my mom like for my entire life as let's
say had this hobby of uh collecting
um kind of like antique kind of like
very uh it doesn't work for it now
because it's kind of become a trend it's
come back in fashion now yeah it's kind
of like very bougie kind of like teacups
and China and stuff like that uh so my
entire life
um I felt like my I was surrounded by uh
like Jenga pieces or the and if I would
make the wrong move then the entire
house would come falling down you know
that's that's how I feel and I I kind of
just got used to it until people like
started coming around my house and
everything like that people with the
merge and people like what's up with all
this China Mouse what's up with that
like when whenever you would like come
home drunk you must be just [ __ ]
sweating
it's like a mission impossible like
Dodge the lasers thing I was just like I
need against my room but there are mugs
everywhere yeah I got the earthquake UK
doesn't have
I don't know how I can properly
verbalize just how much how many like
Precious it's just like Antiques and
like mugs it like goes up the stairs she
she has literally like filled up every
wall with like nice Fine China like my
plates okay we don't have posters I
don't I never grew up with having
posters or paintings in my wall my walls
were filled with plates and China
glasses okay that's that's what my walls
for oh and yeah by complete by complete
I don't know who it feels coincidence or
Nice Like luck they've come into fashion
so she's uh ended up being like she's
like selling she's able to like turn
this Hobby and uh turn it into like kind
of like a hobby where she can make money
out of because holy [ __ ] people people
buy this for like a [ __ ] ridiculous
price in Asia oh yeah yeah it's I I I
don't I hope I'm hoping none of my mom's
customers watch this because they buy it
for like a very very high price I'm like
[ __ ] I saw you buy this for 50
pence on the car boot sale what wait
flying demand man man
as well as demand it's like a lifetimes
well like I could see my lifetime's
worth my mom going to car boot sales
buying this [ __ ] for like 50p a pound a
piece like that's not gonna come back
I'm like selling it for like a God knows
inflation yeah good on your mum but
please keep selling them because I want
my house back I want to walk in my house
and not feel like I'm going to break
something Jesus so yeah it's uh it's
yeah it was it was it was slightly weird
growing up with that kind of environment
okay actually this is the this is remind
me about a totally different topic okay
decorating a room right
my room my house was always decorated
with as I've said like teacups and
places something like that so I never
really got to like let's say I never
really got to a point where I knew what
to do with decorating my own room I
never had posters I never had like
different things in my room to like show
my own personality what like
I'm I'm guessing you put a lot of like
music posters in your room and stuff
yeah that right I I don't even know how
to get posters
what do you mean how do I get them what
do you mean just go you go to stores I
don't have money are we getting this
money from that there were like three
bucks no like the good push like five
pounds in the UK you don't get the good
ones you get the [ __ ] ones so I only
ever put shitty posters up when it came
like a magazine for free yeah and I I
don't think I also that's why you start
off yeah I think I got a free
a poster of Halo and like Halo Reach or
something and I put that [ __ ] on there
did you ever have trouble like
decorating your room in University
because I didn't decorate my room
you didn't at all no it was a little
like a Serial Killer's room I I had
nothing on the walls nothing I I didn't
get in my head I was like why would I
decorate like I'm leaving this room in a
year oh that's true that's true but I've
seen some University rooms and they are
like filled to the [ __ ] brim with
like different stuff and I was like how
the [ __ ] are you affording this yeah I
think I never decorated ever
had like one poster and that was it it
was okay I think I think I bought one
poster just so like if anyone came in
here they wouldn't think they were going
to a seriously it was I think it was
like a [ __ ] start Scarface poster
I was just like let me buy something
from like the university fair and I was
like what's something I can buy that's
cheap that would also make me feel like
a normal person scar faces Scarface is
that poster that's on the brink of like
I'm a normal person but I'm a little bit
quirky
he was just waiting for the Wolf of Wall
Street to come out yeah so you put a
different poster up because I was like
well
I can't put anime on my wall that's
that's that's just that's out of the
question that just means uh that just
means I'm just going to be shunned from
every social group in Universe yeah back
when anime wasn't accepted so I was like
how do I let me pretend to be a normal
human but let me scientifically work
this out what is something I can put on
my wall that's like oh I got a little
bit of Personality
quirky it's either Scarface or pulp
future yeah
choices like either Scarface or Pulp
Fiction and that was it I just always
wanted to spend money on food so I
thought I'm not gonna decorate my room
it's dumb I'm also like if I'm moving
like every year what's the point in
decorating I you know I just put a PC in
my room did you move every year uh yeah
every single year of University I moved
oh [ __ ] oh wow okay so the first year I
was in student dorms and in the UK I
don't know if I was in your University
of mine uh you're only allowed to be in
student dorms for one year and then you
had to find your own accommodation ah
and then obviously because like you know
some roommates propped out and some
roommates yeah you know um whatever like
people changed so I just always moved
every year yeah when I was only in
University for three years yeah so you
know I was I was living at home so I was
just lucky decorating my own room like I
had this like weird conversation with
Sydney the other day
um because like Sydney was like Sydney
Sydney found this like [ __ ] up movie
Iceberg tier list kind of thing and I
think I've watched that we've watched
that I think yeah it's not like the two
and a half hour one on YouTube no she
just found like the image of it right oh
and I come home and she's like I'm I'm
thinking about like going through this
Iceberg I was like Sydney don't don't do
not [ __ ] do that
um because I I I I I don't really like
horror movies and I'm not really like
into I don't really have like I have
morbid curiosity but I've never I've
been
but you also have a sense of reason I
also have a sense of reason as well but
I ended up I I looked at the iceberg
tier list and I ended up realizing that
I've seen a lot of this a lot of these
movies and the reason because of that uh
is because uh when I went to University
there was a phase where people like like
your roommates you always knew that a
[ __ ] one guy that would try to like
show you the most [ __ ] up thing that
they could find whether it be something
like a Serbian film or other like things
they found on something on like Reddit
50 50 or something yeah and Sydney had
just like never experienced that so I
was like I was like realizing is this is
this a me thing that no it happened in
my face yeah it's either in high school
or in college like you had that one yeah
it was in high school for me it was like
that one kid that was just like do you
know what Reddit 50 50. they're trying
to like listen everyone yeah yeah me
spinning everyone lemon party everyone
it made me wonder if it's still a phase
because I think it became a phase
because of [ __ ] like you know two girls
one cup and everything like that so I'm
like do the good old days it's it's like
anyone in University now anyone in
college or high school is there is this
still a thing for sure where are you
guys still showing each other two girls
as long as long as there's the internet
if someone wants to be a little age Lord
of course involved right that's that's
how life is God I saw some of the most
traumatic [ __ ] in high school just
because of that one [ __ ] friend yeah
to that one friend who is not a friend
anymore [ __ ] you like you've literally
scarred me for life of some of the [ __ ]
that you've shown me I do not want to
like I don't know oh no it's horrible
yeah